[Musique]
pour bosco c'est l'heure de la promenade
chaque jour une demi-heure dans les
vignes accompagné par membres de la spa
il fait partie des 3000 animaux
accueillie chaque année par
l'association et attend une adoption 6 6
chiens sur dix se retrouvent leurs
propriétaires ce n'est le cas que pour
un tiers des chats perdus
et quand on sait que la spa de colmar ne
pratique pas l'euthanasie des animaux
on comprend que le refuge ne désemplit
pas pour remplir sa mission
la structure peut compter sur une
trentaine de bénévoles actifs investis
corps et âme par passion mais si
importante soit sa mission l'association
traverse une période de remous
budgétaire c'est-à-dire en fait le
budget de la spa c'est de l'ordre de 550
mille euros et la moitié du budget est
consacré aux frais vétérinaires
étant donné que tous les ans le nombre
de nos pensionnaires montrent donc les
frais vétérinaires augmente augmente
augmente on était un budget de l'ordre
de 225 mille euros la seule source
d'économies conséquentes c'était d'avoir
notre propre cabinet avec notre
vétérinaire salariés nice baie on espère
puisque le projet coûtera de l'ordre de
200 à 1000 pour la structure est à peu
près trente mille euros de plus
d'équipements donc le retour sur
investissement normalement devrait être
de quatre à cinq ans maximum
donc pour nous c'était extrêmement
critiques pour la survie de
l'association et de l'accueil des
animaux d'aller dans ce sens pour
financer son projet la spa de colmar
peut compter sur ses sources de
financement habituel
les dons et les legs comptant pour une
bonne part dans l'équation mais pour un
tel investissement
la structure a dû se tourner vers
d'autres soutient tant est qu'on apporte
quand même quelque chose à
l'agglomération
on ne se dit pas pourquoi pas solliciter
les élus et les sensibiliser à notre
problématique
donc on a sollicité nos élus qui nous
ont écoutés très gentiment est très
favorablement et on a eu la bonne
surprise de recevoir ses 10000 euros qui
vont être quelque chose pour nous le
conseil départemental a créé en fin 2016
le fonds de territoriale de solidarité
qui a été mis en place en place en 2010
est pour une durée de trois ans et ce
fonds de solidarité permet à nous
conseillers départementaux de financer
des projets d'associations
au travers de ce fonds chaque canton
dispose d'une enveloppe annuelle de 100
mille euros pour soutenir des projets
d'investissement associatif une façon de
soutenir ceux qui font vivre les
territoires
c'est une vraie richesse pour le pôle
territoires c'est cette densité
associative mais on sait bien aussi que
le nerf de la guerre pour les
associations pour qu'elles puissent se
développer
et bien c'est l'aspect financier et la
spa joue un rôle particulièrement
important le sujet qui les préoccupe
c'est à dire venir en aide aux animaux
qui sont qui sont perdus aux animaux qui
sont maltraités est un sujet de société
particulièrement important sur lequel
nous voulions apporter une intervention
forte de notre part on quitte le refus
de la spa pour se rendre dans le centre
de colmar à deux pas de la gare le
cercle saint martin un haut lieu de la
vie associative de la pile autant qu'un
bâtiment chargé d'histoire
très vieille bâtisse datant de 1895 et
qui est un lieu extrêmement connue de
colmar ya aidés non colmarien puisqu'ils
s'y déroulent
beaucoup de manifestations c'est un lieu
très vivant et en plus de ceci a donc
effectivement des associations que ce
soit des associations sportives
l'association culturelle également qui
se réunissent et qui pratique dans les
différentes salles du cercle des
activités facile d'accès ouvert à de
nombreuses associations disposant d'un
parking
le cercle possède de nombreux atouts
mais ce qui fait son charme est aussi
l'un de ces principal défaut ces
bâtiments si charmant soit ils
nécessitent un entretien constant et de
nombreuses rénovations une charge
financière importante pour la structure
dernier en date sur la longue liste des
travaux le changement des portes de la
grande scène elles sont faits têtus 5
comme vous pouvez le voir
et elles vont être réparées je pense
début d'année les commandes sont passées
nous avons eu l'accord des subventions
donc on va y aller coût de l'opération
24000 euros dont 60 pour cent seront
financés par une subvention du conseil
départemental
au titre du contrat territorial
d'investissement ça rentre à la fois
dans les compétences du département mais
également dans nos objectifs à martin
dietrich et à moi et aux engagements
qu'on avait pris durant la population
lors des élections départementales
c'est à dire faciliter le lien social si
le remplacement de trois portes en bois
peut vous paraître trivial derrière
cette opération un double enjeu des
économies d'énergie d'une part et la
pérennité de l'association d'autre part
est vraiment il fallait le faire sans
l'aide sans ces aides là le cercle ne
pourrait pas survivre ça n'est pas
possible
le coût d'entretien du cirque est énorme
c'est extrêmement lourd et nous avons
besoin des élus pour le maintenir en vie
ca c c'est vital c'est indispensable au
niveau de leur canton les élus disposent
d'un autre outil pour apporter un coup
de pouce financier aux associations
voire même à des particuliers dans le
besoin
chaque conseiller dispose d'une petite
enveloppe qui permet de dépanner
quelques dizaines ou centaines d'euros
pour soutenir des pros
et où une personne en grande détresse le
fondateur du culturel et social le fixe
qui permet effectivement de dépanner les
associations ont dépanné des gens
individuellement des personnes qui sont
en situation de besoin de secours
d'urgence
donc là également un petit coup de pouce
mais très dont le maximum est de 400
euros que l'on peut dépanner
donc c'est un petit coup de pouce mais
qui est toujours la bienvenue évidemment
au niveau des associations
ainsi outre les projets associatifs et
le soutien à des personnes en grande
précarité se font par exemple servi à
financer les sorties scolaires